(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Hidden
away in the Tuscan hills
of northern Italy,
this beautiful Moorish
castle was built in 1605,
but for more than two decades,
it's been sitting empty.
There are 365 rooms in the
Castello di Sammezzano,
one for every day of the year.
The Moroccan-style palatial villa
is a labyrinth of exquisitely tiled rooms,
each one intricately unique.
The castle was once a luxury
hotel, restaurant, and bar,
but closed its doors in the early 1990s.
It wasn't until 2013 that a
local non-profit committee
was founded to help raise awareness
for the increasingly decaying castle.
They have no ownership of Sammezzano,
but they help to arrange and
promote rare public openings.